anh ạ
anh alo cho các bạn alo
anh vẫn là một cách đột ngột nào đó
không theo một cái thời gian cố định
đúng ạ bây giờ tự nhiên bây giờ 10 giờ
chiều hôm thì bây giờ 30 hôm thì
Anh ở Trung Hà Hội 18 giờ ngày kia thế
Xin chào các bạn cũng phải ngóng chờ
nhưng thực ra thì
mình mình thì cũng không ý định là sơ đồ
sẽ trộn cần các bạn phải vào đúng rợ
đúng hiểu mình coi phim cái lập tức các
bạn vào ngay thì nên là thế nên là mình
mới luôn để sờ cố định được học và 8 giờ
nóng ạ Bạn nào tôi cần đúng 8 giờ cùng
đó là một ngày tâm sự để cho và sớm và
cần phải canh hơn một tí không thì cứ
đúng 5:00 thôi
Xin chào các bạn
Hôm nay mình sẽ tranh thủ
Thật ra thì À cái à
các video Xem lại video là
bộ phim quân sự video nói cái gì cơ
ea2 ừ
ạ bây giờ thử cũng lao lắm rồi Ừ
nhưng mà nó vẫn hay vì thấy râm chỗ chưa
sẽ lại thấy lượng người tương tác
432.000 đổ lên chỉ còn video da màu 26
Đây là video ở trong Facebook thì nó
đánh giá là có 3 phút thì tụi tôi nhớ
như là ba phút là lượng tương tác sẽ
không được 3 phút đổ lên thì mới lượng
người ta mới được cao còn xuống thì sẽ
kiểu nó sẽ bóp về từng tay nó thành ra
mà được lần này chúng ta là kiểu đổ chia
sẻ của thứ giữa Xem 10 triệu rồi Thôi
chia sẻ bình luận nó thứ nhận được cái
tỷ lệ tương tác khi mà xem video này cao
thành ra là thì là gạo video mới được
đẩy lên như thế
à à
khi xảy ra con các bạn có thể tra thêm
khá nhiều cái khái niệm về
khái niệm về việc là khi mà đẩy một cái
bài đăng nào đó lên như thế này giống
kiểu các mạng xã hội khác mỗi mạng xã
hội được sẽ có kiểu cách đẩy riêng của
cái cái bài đăng này là Sử là cái bài
đăng này có thể đang tận à tháng bảy đây
tháng 7 năm ngoái nhưng mà vẫn được đẩy
lên trán ý của tôi bởi vì lượng tương
tác mà vẫn con vẫn cao nhưng mà một vài
một vài mạng xã hội Sự giống như là
Everest ở Ngạn thằng nó đi thì tưởng là
lượng tương tác ở bên đấy rất là khủng
là sự ra nó thường hay chơi theo cơ chế
là kiểu khoản hoàn thành khi tơi thường
ngày theo cơ chế kiểu trên Đinh là kiểu
nó chỉ ý tiện nó luôn ưu tiên những cái
hàng nằm trong
24 giờ phổ biến chữ nó không đẩy cái bài
thực sự cũ lên Thế nên là khi mà quá 24
giờ ấy vì nó có thuật toán về tôi cho
tiền thì bây giờ mấy ông chứ vào cho mà
em xem việc về lô thuật toán à
đúng không kia baroc
thuật toán ở miễn phí mà ở tù quân xử
Banking
a new Ranking
tôi tôi cũng phải làm gần đây tôi phải
làm vụ này để mà đầy sản phẩm lên sản
phẩm như các thứ thứ
các
bác sĩ ở đây là nói qua về thời toán ví
dụ của Credit này có hai cần lưu này đấy
thì nó sẽ có cái nó còn nếu nhớ lôgarit
không Ừ tôi gà tôi quên rồi anh em tôi
chỉ nhớ đại khái à Nó chị nó sẽ luôn nhỏ
hơn nó sẽ luôn cận tiệm cận đến một nên
nó không được lớn hơn mối resist nó thấy
gì phải đại khái là kiểu khi mà quá được
20 24 giờ ấy kể cả điểm tương tác là k
cho thế nào cho nữa Nó không cái cái
nóng nhân và lôgarit nên thành ra họ sẽ
không giờ vượt quá những cái bài đăng
mới đăng nếu mà nó quá 24 giờ hãy trở
thế cái nơi đây có khá nhiều cái này
công thức toán của nó tôi từng đem về áp
dụng của công ty ngày khalid này này Ừ
để mà đây để mà kiểu đánh giá xem một
cái bài đăng nào đó bán được đẩy lên new
feed của người dùng hay không thì tôi
bảo đấy Thằng đấy đi thì nó nó chưa tròn
là kiểu nó không trong vòng 24 giờ nó sẽ
đây Thời gian đăng bài Quan Trọng Nhất
3-bài mới sẽ anh cao hơn bài cũ đấy Cho
dù kể cả được bài cũ được pgđ cao như
thế nào cho nữa thì thì bài mới nhất đôi
khi ở vẫn sẽ được ưu tiên sau 24 giờ có
gì cũng sẽ trên được cái bài mà iPhone
nó lên đến 10 triệu thì nó vẫn có thể bị
xuống vì nó nhân hàm số lôgarit
à à
ờ ờ
Ừ tự nhiên lại chém trên thu chén bát
tràng hi vọng là mình công và sau Trời
ông ấy phải xem lại đầu video nóng lạnh
không Béo ngấy
lại bỏ lỡ một cái kiến thức gì đó
thôi bây giờ đầu tiên tâm sự thì hôm nay
không ai thừa ngày vui của mình gửi hôm
nay là ngày á thế kỷ niệm mình à chờ đợi
chờ
khi gài khi mà đến tầm tuổi đời tôi nhận
ra chính thức là tối 25 tuổi và không ạ
thì thôi còn không tin nữa thôi anh em
tôi tôi nghĩ tôi tầm hai mấy rồi
anh em ấy ở đây Ăn gì để tôi vẫn nghĩ
tới khi tôi mới ra trường đi Trời thế
thì
thôi trẻ con đó
mặt trẻ con này có thư và kiểu sự cái
nón lá gửi tôi vẫn nghĩ tôi rất còn trẻ
kiểu tôi đưa tôi đi tôi là con lịch sự
nữa nhưng Thành Long hiểu Khi mà đi đền
hình đi Ăn đi Ăn uống gì gì đó hoặc à
Nói chung là sử dụng các dịch vụ gì đó
nhá thì có nhân viên người ta kiểu tôi
như người ta tận tâm mình Văn hồng ngoại
thì tôi toàn nói là em cảm ơn chị này
sao rồi Em cảm ơn anh này các thứ thứ ở
Thổ luôn sao mình kiểu mới phát hiện hệ
nhà tuổi hàng của mình nhỏ hơn có mấy
tuổi liền rồi cả mình cảm thấy là mình
bắt đầu lớn tuổi hơn những cái người đấy
thôi trước thì mình kiểu còn Lịch sự chứ
ăn đến bây giờ vợ tôi vẫn lịch sử Cảm ơn
anh Cảm ơn chị như người ta bạn còn nói
lại tôi là cả em mới 2k mấy thôi
Thế kiểu trận nhận ra mình ra lại cái gì
ở nhà tôi vẫn lịch sự tôi bạn sẽ hiểu
Khi mà không biết tuổi người ta mà kể
với tuổi tôi Đôi khi những gọi anh chị
hiểu nó xả ra rồi này
anh
nói chung là tôi thì được ra là tội
chẳng có tổ chức sinh nhật hai cái gì cả
và lớn lớn rồi với nghĩa ngày này nó nó
không
anh vẫn là một ngày mình nó còn mẫu ơi
nhưng mà ý à Không hẳn là chọn đồ quan
trọng rồi nhờ rồi còn bé không cần tổ
chức cái gì
Ừ tôi cần ăn hết đi
Ừ không hẳn là sợ người khác biết bến
thì cửa làm Mong Người khác nhớ đến vân
sáng ai cơ thôi còn được nhận lời chúc
từ một người trên Linh cần chẳng đứng ở
dưới ai ngờ trở lên cần Hình như hồi nãy
tôi để lỡ để là người trong
Ninh đã từng Luyện à Gọi nhau trong vòng
nên là nó dùng được ở trong vòng nên là
trong mối quan hệ với tâm linh cần ra
nhận thế thì biết được ngày sinh
ở họ Chút mình mình ở xã giao là tôi lấy
hình tôi tôi tra để tôi Hủy cài đặt luôn
một ngày tôi không muốn coi chút ôm cái
xã Giao cả và thì ra cũng không
không câu nệ về mấy cái việc đó có người
nhớ hãy Vân người chúc hai người tặng
cái gì đó
Ừ nếu tôi không quan trọng với vấn đề
đâu đây như vui khi mà có ai đó nhớ đến
nhưng mà ở Nói chung là cũng đã từ lâu
rồi tôi không thể trước gì mà thực ra
ngày này tôi nghĩa nó không hẳn quan
trọng lắm
anh alo ở ngày hôm nay được ra có cái có
quan trọng đó là
Ving Future lấy ngày này là ngày ở
Anh Vinh dành cho các thành tựu thứ giao
thừa ngày hôm nay này đấy
cho hết vào lẫn cả bên vợ tôi hôm nay
cũng bốc thăm get away tận hai ngày nghỉ
à
à à
Ờ Ờ
thôi tiếp theo cứ tâm sự nhé
mà đấy thì hôm nay tôi nói vui một tí
gửi kìa hôm nay là công ty tôi có có
buổi họp nhanh từng thành từng thành
viên để mà kiểu xem xét tăng lương
thường là 6 tháng một lần thì đây là lần
thứ hai tôi được tăng
thì anh nhiên này thì xem xét đấy gọi
xem xét thôi nhưng mà thấy ảnh được tăng
lương Thôi chung
và đương nhiên cũng nói qua về mấy cái
chỗ thưởng phụ cấp nó thử Hữu thì
ý
thì cái à
Ừ cái lúc mà tôi biết được à Sẽ Được
Thưởng ấy
Thế mà bảo là được thưởng gì à Có kiểu
dạng là có cố gắng rồi cậu lại chăm chỉ
Vân ấy không biết tôi nói gì không
Ừ Thế bảo đã Nếu thế thì chắc là em sẽ
chia một phần thưởng của em để mà biếu
sếp
như nó hơi vô lý vì rõ ràng là
sẽ và người đưa tiền mình thường mình
không Mình quay lại chuộc lại xếp nhưng
mà Bởi vì à à
Xin chào bạn Kha Ngọc Hà
Anh Khánh Ngọc Hà Hồ Ngọc Hà Phạm
Hồ Ngọc Hà
ờ ờ
anh nói chung Hà nhắc nhớ người vụ được
xếp đấy Thì
bởi bởi vì thực ra thì không biết được
mấy ông còn như tôi không nhưng tôi từng
nói đó là tôi khá là kiểu tâm huyết với
công việc và cũng cũng có tí đồng cảm
với sếp mujeres của tôi cũng ah
anh cũng là một người hiểu
Ừ Tôi từng nói với ông với khái niệm
leader hơn cả
post chưa nhỉ là một xếp so với kiểu là
một người điểu kiểu kiểu dẫn đầu à Dùng
kiếm ít bơ lãnh đạo đúng rồi lãnh đạo
thế hắn chỉ là người ta cùng cố gắng
cùng mình là chính là người cổ đi đầu
luôn để mà kiểu cậu
đi đầu tiên phonh rồi gánh rất nhiều
việc thì sẽ thứ đấy
Ừ thì thì cái á Sếp của tôi đúng như là
một leader áo kiểu làm rất nhiều việc ôm
rất nhiều việc sợ vẫn rất cố gắng thôi
nhiều Và cũng cậu rất là tính cách nói
cho mọi thứ tôi thế à Sếp của tôi trở
dạng hơn rất nhiều sếp luôn ngày có thứ
mà tôi gà tội có 23 sếp mỗi sếp có một
kiểu riêng có xe thì cái sẽ vừa rồi là
sếp bên công nghệ nên là kéo cùng anh em
cùng chiến lược và 1 sếp nữa là xét ra
cũng kiểu dạng làm bên mà kinh doanh
thành ra là thứ nhất là có nhiều tiền
nên thằng gạo cũng không không biết cứ
mỗi lần không biết làm gì để giúp đỡ anh
hem hiện tại huyện vung tiền cho anh em
đầu tư cho anh anh dẫn người thứ ở mua
đầy đủ bánh nước từng đó rồi đó là cứ
hồi mà còn đi làm của công ty là một
tháng về hai phát phải xuống băng một
đống thùng nước em ạ anh em cậu cứ gọi
mong xơ bò húc xong rồi cà phê dew kia
có ca nó dùng đứa kia mỗi lần đấy hết 34
triệu thì vẫn tiền nước chưa đấy thì mới
biết được kiểu xếp hoàn toàn xả cho anh
em như nào ạ
Anh ấy thì tôi định nó là tôi định chị
trích một phần lại vì
tôi sẽ hiểu
điều lại xếp cái xếp về công nghệ kìa về
thực sự anh ấy rất chịu khó tôi coi anh
đấy kiểu dạng đúng như kiểu dạng này một
người không không không còn khái niệm và
xếp nữa một người hoàn toàn là được hi
sinh vì khi sinh tháng yêu ấy bởi vì anh
đấy Kiểu
on berceuse giờ nào cũng được vì công
việc có nhiều thứ không vừa nói cái
giọng ở dạng tao bế trên của mày mày
phải giao vân vân tí đưa anh ấy cũng có
cái độ bảo thủ không phải bạt tôi tôi
nghĩ à
bài hát hồi một phần thôi
Ê mi
Mỹ Đồng nghiệp của tội còn nói là anh
thì có tí hơi bảo thủ ngủ tí chúng tôi
không thể nghe Hàn đã bảo thủ lắm chắc
là bởi vì tính tôi lắm thế không biết
được nếu một phần ở chắc là tôi không
hẳn là thân với anh để làm nhé
cho tụi tôi nói chuyện được với anh đấy
và tôi thuyết phục được anh đấy nhưng mà
nhưng mà không biết được mấy kia thế nào
nhưng mà nó là như thế này
anh ấy anh Mạnh Tuấn từng chia sẻ đó là
anh thấy cách nói chuyện của em khác là
cách nói chuyện với ai kia rồi đấy mình
ra khác mấy người kia bảo anh ấy vào thù
và người kia Toàn kìa dụng Ví dụ nhé
dừng mấy cái kia đưa ra ý kiến cá nhân
rồi à Phản 3 ý kiến của anh đấy
à mà không hiểu đề xuất các giải pháp
kiểu gì gì đó mà chỉ bảo là cách làm anh
thấy sai phạm tán anh ấy như thế thôi
nhưng mà cũng chẳng nói thêm có dạy cách
giải quyết như thế nào hay tranh luận vì
lẽ lắm đấy các thứ
cuối cùng cả hai bên cả ai nghe cả con
còn tôi thì tôi thường ai nói một đống
hướng cho anh đấy rồi anh đấy thấy cái
nào phù hơn rồi tôi đứng nhờ tội Nhiều
lúc nói là anh đấy là kiểu cái này em
thấy hợp lý hơn mã Vân có lúc anh nghe
tôi có lúc không nhớ là tôi về cơ bản
thì tôi nghĩ là bởi vì cái mục tiêu của
anh đấy là mục tiêu của tôi hoàn toàn
hay hai người giống nhau đó là đó ra gì
đều muốn cho cái dự án tốt lên để muốn
nó phát triển hơn mình đánh hết sức vì
nó đấy còn những điệu người kia thì tôi
thể thời gian những người kia
và đương nhiên là họ có kiến thức họ đưa
lấy ý kiến của họ nhưng họ của cái tôi
học kiểu à kéo Dạ thấy sếp không hẳn
kiểu không theo ý mình và khó chịu Vân
lại các thứ thứ
à mà không hề nhận ra rõ ràng cả hai
người đang cái mục đích ban đầu và hai
người đều là nói về cậu về kiểu
em muốn muốn cái dự án này đi lên mà
đúng không Cuối cùng thành hơi tiêu cực
đáng kiêu thế
khi
đôi khi chúng ta phải luôn xác định này
có mục tiêu ban đầu nóng hạ mục tiêu ban
đầu nó là gì
Em đừng có cãi nhau thôi cùng làm mất đi
Không mục tiêu ban đâu không ạ
Nói chung là đấy phê Sếp của tôi Tôi cảm
thấy tôi muốn trích một phần cải lương
mà tự khám không phải thưởng thưởng rồi
vì thực ra là sếp cũng giúp tôi khá
nhiều không được chưa đến lúc tôi cũng
có những pha đi vào lòng đất có chứ tôi
sẽ cũng phải hội chợ tôi như khoản về
việc đây vật hỗ trợ ở đây hỗ trợ việc đi
pause thứ bởi vì hiệu Sếp tôi là một
người đã học thuật toán rất là tốt
Xem tivi toán thiếu thứ có lôgic các thứ
là tốt
anh nói cho
mẹ tôi từ trước ngày tôi gặp được khá
nhiều người khá giỏi tuệ mà học hỏi bộ
phiên mấy ông nên như thế kiểu tìm những
tìm được à công việc mà có sếp giỏi em
mình học hỏi nó sẽ tốt ngoạn tiếp theo
cái này về à khi đóng góp cho cộng đồng
thì ở dẫn công nghệ Mình đóng góp cho
gội đầu thì mình à Nên góp như thế nào
đúng ạ Nó góp những gì nhất là hồi mà
tôi mới vào chưa tin công ty tôi đóng
góp cộng đồng Tôi ngồi đây tôi chưa biết
về
Tôi chưa giỏi lập trình Những này nha
Tôi chỉ đóng góp thiếu kiểu lại có những
cái câu hỏi làm tra Google nó dễ chứ tra
hộ người ta xong rồi tôi trả lời hộ mày
ra đấy Nói chung là tôi đang nổi sôi
động vốn từ trưa nay vẫn thế Đấy xong
rồi Nếu mà bây giờ mấy mấy ông tại hơn
đấy thì mới ông có thể đương nhiên là
thể lên mấy cái trang kiểu trang diễn
đàn ví dụ special lâu rồi xong rồi vibro
rất nhiều diễn ra những thứ Nếu mua là
viết hẳn bài của ông chia sẻ nhiều nước
quá tốt ai thì ông đấy thôi Cái ở trên
chính sách of clothes là diễn đàn với
hỏi cũng rất nhiều cậu có hỏi
anh ở đây hoàn toàn là có thể mấy ông có
thể trả lời được rồi bởi vì tra Google
phát ra nhưng mày không này lười không
đi cha dân em nữa thứ tư Nếu mày ông
hoàn toàn đồng có đóng góp như thế cái
việc đóng góp ở đây có lợi điểm là thứ
nhất à cái trang cá nhân của ông sẽ được
đánh giá rất là cao mà tăng điểm Vân
tương tự dùng pin đi hát cũng thế Nếu
không phải lên cho Suốt những cái này
của vì cho nhà Tuyển dụng hay rất nhiều
thứ ứng kịch bản thân cái cộng đồng
công nghệ nhìn vào ông và nó cũng kiểu
tôn trọng không ấy cái bóng đóng góp
nhiều đấy Nói chung vào đấy Đấy cách mà
kiểu người ta nhìn nhận và tôi nói thế
như cao tuổi có bị tôi chưa đóng góp
được nhiều trance techno Floor nhưng mà
tôi tôi thấy đã từng có rất nhiều người
Việt hẳn hoi cả con gái luôn tôi từng
gặp 34 người trả lời rồi trận nó ra đấy
tên tiếng Việt mà ngoại rồi con gái đẻ
và ta con gái tên là con gái Tôi nghĩ
vấn đề thật đấy đấy thì
em không có qua thứ
em tự sự tôi thấy nể mấy người ấy phết
không biết mày Ông thấy thế nào
Ừ cái đôi khi là chỉ những cách đơn giản
thế thôi không cần chúng ta phải màu mè
theo kiểu phải lên tivi phải gọi lên báo
cái gì đó chính bản thân mình nổi mình
có tên tuổi mình kiểu
không hẳn hẳn là có tên tuổi như nói
chung và mình có đóng góp cho cộng đồng
không ạ Nó là giống như bây giờ giả sử
và một cái cái tài khoản ghi hát cùng
mấy ông sẽ rất ngoài khi ở mấy ông đã đã
có cái ác con Gmail ký để xem các
preview này mà ông ở Tân con Chi Pu và
những cái kèo Mày cái lớn thôi cũng sẽ
chị
đã sự tôi từng đóng góp được vào à máy
cày có cái đất này không buồn cười
mấy cái này tự không hạt nổi lắm đã thử
nhưng mà cuộc kháng chiến bưu là tên tên
bản thân mình ấy vợ chồng nó cũng hãnh
diện mà Đấy những người đã đóng góp có
Minh vào chồng quá hãnh diện Hàn anh
kiểu thế
Ừ hi vọng về sau em cũng mấy mấy ông
cũng kể có cái thuế trong ai cực đặc
biệt trong những cái kiểu dự án lớn của
tự nhiên có ông là người đã từng đóng
góp không để chỉ chỉ một vài dòng cũ
thôi nhưng mà mai rồi à
và tiếp theo đó là
xem video
cha mẹ
Ừ anh yêu tôi và thì anh làm gì để chứng
tỏ anh yêu tôi là làm có thêm chả làm
được rửa bát quét nhà rửa chân cho mượn
mẹ nó nhảy vui mỗi ngày nào này nhảy vào
lửa để trở thành con suốt thôi ạ đó thôi
mà làm vui lòng vợ tao cũng nhảy nhất
[âm nhạc]
anh yêu tôi vào thì anh làm gì để chứng
tỏ anh yêu tôi là làm có thêm chả làm
được rửa bát quét nhà rửa chân cho mượn
nó nhảy qua lợi ích này này này này vào
lửa để trở thành con suốt thôi ạ chó
thôi mà làm vui lòng vợ tao gặp cảnh rất
Ừ không biết rồi Các bạn có tuổi thơ ở
xem cái này không cả hai cái này nó là
tôi nhớ là lên voi xuống chó phải không
nghỉ à
ừ ừ
ô tô kỹ sư cái rồi
tên nhớ anh như là hài Thế có xuống chó
gì đó
lên voi xuống chó à
em lên voi thôi nên bỏ luôn không không
này à
mẹ con mình của bạn trai
của mình
em xem có mình bạn kia
à À cái này anh yêu tôi vào thì anh làm
gì để chứng tỏ anh yêu tôi là làm thêm
cả làm được rửa bát quét nhà rửa chân
cho mượn nó nhảy vui mỗi ngày này nhảy
vào lửa để trở thành con chó thôi Anh
yêu tôi và xinh đấy thì sau chính xác
ok thi rồi cái nói chung là cái cái cái
video đấy ở trong bộ phim đấy thì hồi
đấy thì sẽ không sẽ bị kiểu bị cho là
kiểu một thằng con trai kiểu
không có
anh không triển vọng được cậu được
không đánh da mặt làm ăn năm nghi với
Vân bởi vì sao có gì à làm những cái
làm những cái việc cậu nhỏ bé giống như
vừa bà nội trợ rồi chọn sẽ làm tổn
thương bản thân vì kiểu một đi có cả từ
nhiều cái thứ thứ không ạ
hồi ấy sẽ bị khinh thường Hồi đấy Chả nó
bị thì không biết bây giờ là nhiều hơn
chắc chắn bị suy nhược hiểu kiểu thằng
thằng con trai mặt đáng mặt Nam nhi đại
trượng phu không ạ thì thì à
tôi thì phải làm những được những việc
to tát vào trong cái phim đấy lần đấy
làm chị là phải ở người có học phải
người có học vấn người làm được cái gì
đó Thật chứ chọc bé là Trạng Nguyên thứ
Đỗ cái gì đó thì mới mới được mà vợ tỷ
trọng ít nhất là vợ này chặt đã sau đó
thì người khác cũng thơ sau này cuối
cuối vị cuối cái đấy thì đúng là
Đạt được như thế thì thì mới cậu nở mày
nở mặt cứ thứ chứ không phải là cái vừa
rồi là kết thúc được video rồi
nhiều người xem qua cái đoạn ngắn Cứ
tưởng phim Thế có hậu em chưa người vợ
gặp được một người chồng dạo này hết sức
chiều mình
à à
ý thì cái này thì tại sao tôi nói thời
đấy Bây giờ Bây giờ thì tôi thấy thứ
nhất là vừa rồi mấy ông thầy đó lượng là
người thân bác rất là k cũng như là các
bình luận rất nhiều bạn nữ rất nhiều bạn
nữ không nói bạn nam mặn bạn Nam Tôi chả
thấy bị gọi bạn làm đấy cả rất nhiều bạn
nữ Bờ Tôi chỉ muốn có ông chồng gửi như
thế vẫn hiểu đã hi sinh viên mình đã
được hơn nhưng mà nhưng mà nó bị sai
nghe chứng tỏ tiêu chuẩn tiêu chuẩn con
trai kiểu người yêu Bây giờ cùng mấy bạn
đấy
anh không biết thế nào nhưng mà
Vì
theo như theo như thế thì khác gì bở
tiêu chuẩn con trai vừa chỉ cần một
người rồi cái gì nhất mình hết hết mình
à vì mình
nhưng mà không Không cần phải cậu dạng
là giỏi giang không cần chạy các dự thứ
Vân sẽ như bị ngược bởi kìa tiêu chuẩn
đã lẽ tiêu chuẩn kiếm yếu Thực ra là
càng cảm
anh khó Hân con người giờ đòi hỏi ngày
càng nhiều hơn Không biết các bạn nữ kia
nói thế làm chỉ là do từng gặp những
người tiêu cực hay là
cho số đông bây giờ không tin tưởng vào
tình yêu đích thực nữa thì ra cậu chỉ
cần người yêu thương mình là đủ rồi hãy
cơ thể
anh nói thế nhà nha Bây giờ mới ông mà
đi tán được mấy bạn đấy rồi bạn là anh
có mỗi tấm lòng ấy xem xem thế nào
anh nói chung là cái video đấy tôi động
kết Tôi muốn nói đó là ờ
Ừ hình như tiêu chuẩn đi là bị đánh giá
sai về tiêu chuẩn của cái video thời đấy
khác hoàn toàn với bây giờ bây giờ được
nổi lên nhưng mà nổi lên theo phong cách
kiểu dạng này
gà trống tình ý giống kiểu anh sẽ là thí
sinh mọi thứ với em
Anh bất chấp ngoại
cho tôi tôi chẳng ủng hộ cái lắm tôi
thôi Đúng trong chuyện tình cảm thì tôi
cũng cũng khờ dại cũng si tình có thứ
nhưng tôi nghĩa là mình cả hai cả hai
cùng nên vì nhau và cùng cùng cậu tốt
lên ý chứ không phải là cậu dạng mà
em chọn một người không có không có nghị
lực gì cả mà dùng từ không nhịn được
cười thì làm những cái kiểu
nhà mình có thể làm được nhỏ bé không có
ý chí phấn đấu như thế mà nó thành xu
hướng thì là xã hội nó sẽ đi xuống rồi
tôi Tôi nghĩ là thế
Vì sao không nói là con trai thì không
nên làm được nhà hay các thứ
nói giờ 00 lên kiểu
chọn kiểu dễ dãi như thế
Tại sao lại dùng từ như hiểu được ý ra
sự những người dân trí thức những dân cố
gắng thứ sẽ không được coi trọng nữa
ngoại chỉ có một ông kiểu dáng làm hết
mọi thứ
lại được coi trọng hơn thì không ổn
không nên mày không hiểu gì tôi không
cho
tôi tôi nghĩa là tôi văn vỡ trạng chỉ
thế thôi nếu hiểu nhiều nha Thôi bây giờ
bắt đầu buổi học mà à
đi câu hỏi
có tiền thì à có bạn vừa nãy hỏi luôn
cái câu này đó là hôm trước là tôi làm
cái biểu đồ lọc
biểu đồ thống kê rồi Bà bảo muốn lọc
theo ngày tháng năm ở
anh cứ lỏng lọc theo ngày tháng năm này
bản chất là các bạn dùng YouTube để mà
lấy nó ra số các bạn là phải lọc được
thôi Đây mình thường mở lại cái bộ trước
nhé
à à
ừ ừ
thì các bạn đúng em ạ
à à
Em hãy vẽ hình chữ này nữa ờ
ở thời sự Cái này đi vì thế các bạn muốn
không phải mặc định 30 ngày ấy có dự này
các bạn muốn hiển thị ra một cái phút ở
trên này chọn nhưng mà chọn xong cứ mỗi
lần thay đổi thì nó sẽ nó sẽ có hai khái
niệm này có thể xảy ra nhá một là các
bạn chọn trợ trong một khoảng thời gian
nghĩa là chọn ngày bắt đầu ngày kết thúc
sau đó thì nó sẽ nó sẽ que theo đúng
trong cái phạm vi đấy đấy đấy Cái thứ
nhất cái thứ hai đó là
các bạn chọn cố định một ngày thôi Chỉ
cho một ngày họ cũng nó làm cho chọn một
tháng nó sẽ thống kê trong bể hàng đấy
cũng được có rất nhiều cách
ở đây tôi sẽ thử ví dụ một cái ở mày
không dễ hình dung nhé Thật sự tôi để
thường dễ nhất thì theo tháng đi đấy
Không Cần Thơ ca không cần nêm ở đây sẽ
có ai đi Ở đây là
à Dạ chẳng cái này đi luôn Mình có thể
là sự bắt sự kiện bon chen thì mà thay
đổi khi mà
trên đó nha ngon khi mà sự kiện thay đổi
thì mình sẽ là
net chat Thằng Hải Ngoại ạ
À mà hôm trước có cái hàm các chatroom
nha À không không Ở đây có hàm cái tra
rồi Nó tên khác đi là trên
mạng đi mà Chuyển bếp đi
trẻ khi mà thằng chạy thì
th2 Đức thống lật đổ ngoạn
ở
những cưới cho nói là không thế giới để
tôi xem lại nha Em không biết được lấy ý
thằng này
Hôm nay tôi làm đơn giản thì trả cho nó
bé đi Dậy lấy ba lô nó đi
gửi tiền lại các anh trước anh
nói chuyện này
nhớ hôm ấy Ông làm cái này không cần ở
đó của mình và đi đây nữa không chỉ cần
là ông Toàn bộ Cái này trong này
Xóa đi là đi Tại sao vì rõ ra là cái này
nó chạy sau nó chạy sau khi mà cái tài
liệu đồ lót rồi
35 bệnh và phải đợi cái này được trên đã
cái này Vừa chạy nhưng mà toàn không cần
lấy đi nữa
ông sẽ thay cái này vào đây đôla đít à
nhầm đôla
chuẩn baru này
với em ăn này
làm ăn thôi
Ừ thế giới nói chung là đổi hết cái đây
mà ăn cái chữ thứ tư
ừ ừ
35 Anh Mang Ok sau đó thì sửa nó cái
file này để làm ăn này
cho mắt bé rồi
ban mình sẽ không làm theo kiểu mắc bếp
mình sẽ que Măng này à
anh à hình như cái mắt này nó còn trả về
cả tháng đấy để tôi xem lại nha
Con solo chuẩn ý nó ăn
trứng như cái này trả về cả anh ý ý là
nó trả về tháng là năm nữa năm nữa
à à
Ừ đúng rồi nó trả về năm nữa chứ tháng
thôi là không đủ
như thế thì mấy ông có thể tách ra
đây sẽ ra cứ cho là men
chuyển sang đây bữa năm tháng được vì
tôi nếu phải tách ra đoạn này thì mấy
ông quen ăn bằng cái măng đấy và Wales
và người kia đấy thì nó sẽ hợp lý hơn
ờ ờ
anh em thể tách ra thì nếu không thấy nó
sẽ cách nhau một cái dấu này này nó
ngoại mình có thể ra
hoặc dùng hàm mũ trước đây format như
này xong rồi set hai thằng nó bằng nhau
ở được quê ở đây nha à
em đổi đây là đây là
u&i đây là thì e ngày thì phải đúng
Ê Ê hôm trước nó là ngày trong tháng
nhà thuốc quý sử Hà Nội à
ở đây mình còn 5 buổi sáng không ạ thì
mình sẽ ở dưới này thương nhớ yên này
bốn chữ số này ở đây là
điên này bằng
chị gửi mắn này là được
à
Tôi đang tô svideo xem đường nhé á
à à
à à mọi chú chạy xuôi chạy tới để bữa
nay chạy nha
chạy đâu mày nghỉ
Xin lỗi tiếng con số 0 vào lỗi
khi chuyển sang à
anh ở đây có chạy
anh ạ
xe tải về rồi copy cái này
này xem chạy đâu nha
anh không Không cần phải dùng hàng đấy
mà mình dùng Chính mẹ FBI Thôi để mà que
không thì dùng pp để mà cắt cũng được
nhiều cách mà
à à
ở đó ngày tháng này tháng mà mình vừa
chọn này nó không ra gì rồi nhưng mấy
ông hiểu cái này không ạ
đó đó là mình sẽ quay theo trong cái
phạm vi đấy mày Cái dưới này thì chắc là
cũng phải sửa vài cái đấy vẫn sửa mấy
ông hiểu gì tôi đấy Đó là mình có thể
theo thống kê theo tháng mà mình đã chọn
lấy một cách
cách cách nữa mà nhiều người cũng thường
hay là đó là kiểu mình sẽ cho bắt đầu từ
ngày bao nhiêu đến kết thúc này bao
nhiêu xong mình sẽ con Nút ấn OK đây này
Nhưng mà ấn vào nút ok đấy mình sẽ lấy
cái dữ liệu từ hai cái cho mình sẽ Dual
nằm trong phạm vi của hai cái ngày đấy
Cứ phân vân Nga Nếu thế cũng phải sửa
lại côn này có này không dùng được nữa
rồi ông ạ ờ ờ
tại khai nói như thế để mà chọn thể lập
được theo một cái gì đó không ạ tiếp
theo thì có bạn hỏi câu này mình từng
nói qua là cái mình từng làm website cho
trường mình
Ừ đấy là thực ra là thứ nhất là nó đồ ăn
hay của mình rồi đấy làm cho cô đấy mình
làm đủ bán hai xong rồi Thầy bảo ốp luôn
như trường thôi đồ ăn cuối tốt nghiệp
của mình cũng làm trong vẫn vẫn tiếp tục
ngồi làm cái đấy cho trường thì à
ở đấy làm mình cảm thấy cũng may mắn em
được làm cái đấy đứng như là cũng bị bóc
lột chất xám ấy bởi vì họ làm họ
Anh bảo mình làm cho cùng không Công
giáo sư thư không ạ
Anh họ gì bây giờ vẫn rung nhớ ra mình
không quan trọng vấn đề đấy lắm à
à mình mình làm đích là để mà giúp cho
kiểu để một quản lý sinh viên mình để
trình sinh viên Mình cảm thấy
ổn hơn với bị hồi đấy à trường mình quản
lý mọi thứ giấy tờ cái thứ mà không biết
rồi mà cậu trường các thứ thứ đôi khi ở
chỗ ấy xe ông ạ xong rồi mày sau còn
thiếu lòng tin mà ngồi không biết được
rồi ông nào đã thiếu điểm môn nào có thử
thứ Quê Tôi làm ngon phết rồi Tôi làm
thống kê thống kê này sau liệt kê bạn
này thiếu môn này nữa môn này sôi đoạn
câu axwell ở đây rồi Khá là nhà BM xem
lại cho tôi Tôi yêu khá nhiều không biết
mấy ông muốn xem cái chàng trường tôm
nhỉ Sợ Xem trang chúng tôi xong mấy ông
ấy bóc phốt à
anh hả
Từ từ tôi cho mấy ông xem qua cây trang
thời trang
trường trường tôi nhá
Ừ để tôi nhớ tôi còn tôi có data BAE để
mà
ở bệnh viện kết này
anh không nói về nhắn quá em không phải
em không có tao bay để mày ông xem qua
rồi thì phải xem ở trên trang thật rồi
vợ đi à
à à
ở đây
ở đây đây là Trang Tôi là có làm cho cả
sinh viên nữa cơ chỗ ngồi sẽ sinh viên
xem vào xem được mình đây tôi nhớ Tôi
làm cả sinh viên Tôi không biết là tôi
đã bỏ đi Chưa ạ
ê ê ê
à à
Ừ đợi thì nhắn để tôi xem lại Phát à
Em có phải tôi tạm cỡ đi rồi cái này
bằng laser với tôi có làm cho cơ chế 1
cây cực bên tôi trở tự sướng thôi đó
thường ai gặp thêm tính năng thì đói tôi
ghi ở trong file Excel rồi Tôi dùng à À
chắc gọi lên phải sao đấy một đọc lại mà
tôi đã cập nhật những cái tính năng gì
hiển thị ngày thời gian cập nhật đấy
cười phết
à À đây thông tin nhạy cảm quá chơi chơi
chơi đi bao nhiêu không biết gì nhé Nói
chung là có quản lý điểm này quản lý mọi
thứ ở đây nè Tôi sẽ cho mấy ông xem mấy
cái thống kê của tôi làm sinh viên này
hệ thống kê kiểu Nga chẳng hạn
em nghỉ học nhiều fake cái này hình như
là tôi nhớ không lầm mà do Cập nhật lại
bị chết ở đây ở trên này có hai cái bảng
cơ bấm ơi chị này bạn này nghỉ nhiều này
chồng xịn đâu tôi vợ tôi thích làm thống
kê rồi mà
tủ lạnh nhiều lớp hơn này có có cái quan
trọng là tôi bảo rồi Nó xuất ra được
danh sách thi nè danh sách thì thống
Ừ cái gì nhỉ tổng kết điểm cho khóa này
tổng kết tổng kết kiểu dạng sinh viên
nào đạt đạt được in điểm ra chỗ ở đây
tôi làm rất nhiều tính năng và lỗi kẹt
mình cười quá
Ừ chắc không có gì đấy Ờ
Xin lỗi cô này
Anh sợ lỗ cốt nhỉ Xóa nạn cô lại đi à
ở chỗ ở vào thoải mái ngồi xóa rồi
anh
nói trọng đại khá như thế rồi tôi làm
rất nhiều cả bên đề bên admin của Lý bên
A
ở cả bên giáo viên ở bên sinh viên để
hiển thị các thứ thứ nữa
anh nói chung là kiểu tôi làm cái trang
web về hơn 2 năm có tâm huyết có thử
nhiều
thế hả mẹ kế hỏi đáp anh à Gần đây thì
gửi ít thời gian đến tội không không cập
nhật ảnh lên các thứ nữa
Ừ đúng rồi vẫn còn anh vẫn có để số điện
thoại đấy vì anh đây còn đợt đầu cốt
động có cốt để mà bổ sẽ lại đâu đã từng
có vài giáo viên mới vào gọi điện cho
anh khi mà cũng vấn đề gì đấy nhanh vẫn
trợ giúp anh nhé chứ anh không còn làm
đấy nữa là thứ anh không nói được cũ rồi
Tao không làm gì nữa mày đi hỏi thằng
khác Không anh vẫn trợ giúp cái Thử ở
chung vào kia à
khi đôi khi nói chung là anh khó chịu
nổi việc về ban lãnh đạo giám đốc có dự
thứ thôi
anh chứ anh không Anh vẫn hoàn toàn
thoải mái với à với kiểu đồng nghiệp
cũng không nghĩa các giáo viên Hà sinh
viên có sự thứ vẫn hỗ trợ hết sức có thể
ngoạn mình làm mình làm cái trang web
xảy ra không phải mục đích vì tiền chúng
ta tôi từ trước lại tự trả lời Làm đi
nhiều tiền mà làm kiểu để mà hỗ trợ được
cái quản lý sinh viên ở trường Thứ ngoại
thì bây giờ tôi vẫn cái gì đâu bạn sẽ hỗ
trợ được rồi tôi vẫn sẽ hỗ trợ không ạ
ở thời đấy lk tôi khá khó chịu về việc
là ban lạnh lạnh còn nghĩ là tôi làm cái
trang web đấy tôi thu thập thông tin
dùng có thể ra lận gần gian lận lương
của tôi cái thứ mà tôi chẳng làm thực là
chẳng
Ừ tôi ngủ muốn làm gì thế là mấy giờ rồi
không chẳng biết chuyện gì thế
à à
thế hả đảng đảng không cái viết đăng ảnh
lên nhóm nhóm của tôi mới có thể đăng
còn được đang để lên 1000 đã khác thì
phải dùng nick của tôi đứng nhờ do ảnh
tôi lọc chứ Cái đấy là mấy ông không hỗ
trợ được
Ừ ok Nói chung mà nãy giờ hơi ra dòng đi
mà trong cái đó buổi không lại rất dài
quay lại buổi hôm nay nhá thì đầu tiên
thì có hai mình nhưng mình bảo là mình
sẽ dạy các bạn về rating tức làm chị là
và đánh giá đúng không ạ đánh giá đây sẽ
đánh giá được cả bằng bình luận lẫn cả
bằng vốt Nghĩa là nghĩa kiểu bầu bầu
nhưng phút một xíu à
Nói chung là nó sao đúng không ạ Thích
sao có thứ thì vừa nãy mình có cha qua
rồi xem còn đấy Không nó ra cái từ khóa
vẫn còn dở ôm bạn gọi chữ đỡ tinh ở trên
coat này bạn sẽ K về tôi Tôi dùng để
được tiên đấy nhé mày không thể dùng mấy
cái sao được Anh ta lại Dũng sẽ thuận
này
tôi thực góp về mình xem nha à
Thật sự tôi tặng phải đây là file demo
chấm atld HM lời đi cái thuận trước đã
tl này phải nằm trong tay phom không ạ
đây sẽ là nhóm để kỹ ở đây nó sẽ có
những cái in bút như thế này thì ra tôi
khá khó chịu ông này khi mà để cái value
của cái nút này lại là có cả chữ cỡ chữ
và số thì tôi sẽ đổ hết thành số
tiếp theo để CF này sẽ đây ta à
a
report này bản chất này nó là chèn lên
file thôi tôi thấy vừa rồi import này lá
lại không hiểu sao tôi thường này để nó
ra ngoài cái hợp lý hơn này à
à à
ừ ừ
có ai sao đây chạy thử loại
ở đó thế xong
thì thì bây giờ tôi sẽ có nút giờ sửa ra
ok là bạn mà phải đánh giá đúng ạ đánh
giá
và mình phải sửa lại cái Blue Thằng này
là do sự là 4.5 này bốn này 3.5 này em
không có phải rồi nha bởi vì theo tôi
từng nói bên lập trình nó bên nước ngoài
thì ra phải có nó là chấm chứ không phải
giống như mình
nói như thế này bây giờ xử tục đánh giá
3.2 2.5 tấn đánh giá này thì ông sẽ thấy
với tinh bằng 2.5 Thế là xong những sẽ
lời Christine ngày về ngoại về để mà kẹo
lưu lại và trong b là tả người dùng ở
đánh giá 2.5 có thể đánh giá sản phẩm
này đánh giá cái thường là đánh giá đơn
mà khách hàng đã đặt khá là hay Tại sao
bé uống để thấy bình luận nữa không ạ
sẽ có cách Alo đây
là chỗ
anh bình luận được ạ
nhưng cả nhà mình sẽ còn nên nó nó là
comment không ạ hiểu ngay
ạ Bây giờ chúng dòng đi
xe ôm không ạ
Em cập nhật từ đó rồi mày ông ấn vào thì
ông sẽ chuyên được thêm cả tuần hai cái
này lên số đón mấy ông đi lại thế là
xong ngủ ngon thì À thì ra cái này có
thể thêm màu mè thêm ảo giác có thứ thứ
là kiểu bấm vào thì nó sẽ không phải lạy
cha Nhưng cái đấy cho tôi dậy mới đúng
rồi tôi không cần nói thêm vào đây
Em
hãy celestine này chắc là khó ở điểm là
mấy ông phải Cấu hình lại đây b thì thì
bây giờ tranh thủ tôi dậy cái khác rồi
mấy ông thử trả lời trả lời tôi nhé đó
là
nghĩ như tôi vừa nói thì có sẽ có 2
triệu đánh giá hai cái hai kiểu đánh giá
là một là anh đánh giá sàn thoại
thì mấy ông sẽ lưu lại chẳng DB ông sẽ
lại tại bảng nào
họ và tên cột 2 mọi thứ là gì không ạ
cách tạo bảng mới hay lưu lại trong bạc
phố đắt vân vân thứ hai là đánh giá đơn
Hà
thì nếu mẹ lưu lại trong dp như thế nào
để em bé uống thử trả lời sai hai câu
này thử sẽ Em tưởng mấy ông bắt bắt đầu
hiểu về cách thiết kế có sợ nghiệm chưa
cái
em lấy mấy ông thử ngồi nghĩ hai con này
nhá Còn bây giờ tôi sẽ dậy cái cái cái
nữa
tiếp theo rồi Life
lãi suất thì hiểu khái niệm les nó gì nó
lại Ví dụ ở đây thôi Khi mà gõ cái gì đó
lên nó sẽ đề xuất ra dưới kiểu iPhone
này
có ai nó sẽ hiển thị ra rửa Nga ơi anh
Phát bạn iPhone rõ ràng đây là bán
laptop này nghỉ
gõ thì ra thật đấy thì ông thấy nó sẽ
hiển thị đề xuất ở dưới đây nó sẽ có
khái niệm là Devil lighstick cảm Tìm
kiếm thời gian thực những có có cái gì ở
trong database méo thì sẽ hiển thị ra
đây luôn cái thứ nhất
và trả về rất nhanh nên thường gọi lãi
suất theo rán thực thứ hai nó là
cái này đô thị được gọi là con
autocomplete tất cả nó sẽ tự động tự
động kiểu điền đầy đủ cho ông bé ông
thêm với ông Ấn vào sẽ tự động đi đâu
đấy Ê thằng Hoa nó nó là nhảy sang chán
khác nhưng mà nhiều nhưng mà bé uống gì
đi thôi không kiểu tự động điền đầy đủ
thì ra méo thể tra luôn gj Chẳng ạ sau
autocomplete và nói chuẩn hơn
cái áo tôi con nít mà chắc là nó lái sơ
kẹo hình hiển thị ra đề xuất các thứ
thôi ấy thì nó có khái niệm của cái thư
viện này và tích hợp cả thư viện bổ sung
thêm của Sulli lại nó dùng cả Ji dùng
thêm của nó nữa nó là cái ui này thì
thực sự K ít người dùng di thì em chẳng
ai dùng thay nữa
em éo hiểu tôi là kẹo vỏ nhé Ấn vào thì
nó sẽ tự động Điền cho mấy ông đấy thì
nó khái niệm ô tô con nít này thì cái
này là nó sẽ một là ông sẽ có sẵn dữ
liệu
anh chuyền vào trong nó để nó gợi ý là
những thế hai mấy ông kết hợp quả rất
đông ạ thì đây xem Suốt này code đây dữ
liệu này dữ liệu có sẵn để mày không tự
động gọi đến cuộc gọi đến cái này nhưng
mà tôi vào rồi Nếu mà thêm vào
lite-server lắm chị ạ Tìm kiếm ở trong
database tính kiến trong bạn khô ráp và
sản phẩm nó nhọn để hiển thị ra đề xuất
ở đây thì mình Họ thì mình sẽ kết hợp
với
Iraq không ạ
hôm nay đi nhà nghỉ à
em có xịn xịn đúng không cộng thêm những
cái kỹ ra khi mạng Metro xong sẽ chỉ ra
cái gì ra màu mè đấy là gái và cái này
thì à lấy dữ liệu từ ra cũng từ đây này
Nhưng tôi muốn lấy dữ liệu từ ạ
nếu không sẽ khái niệm remote làm chỉ là
cái nối đến cái nơi khác không ạ ra cái
quạt à
à à
em bớt bắn chim đại bàng ở Ego vậy g
Ừ bắt đầu không trả lời cái gì
em bớt chim tự nhiên tôi quên hết con
chim ảnh chim cút là gì à Halloween à
anh không Chả biết mình con gì mà luôn
bấm thử nhé
ờ ờ đấy thì thì cái suốt của nó lần này
nè sẽ gọi đến file pp Thấy quen không
yêu cầu bắt buộc nhỏ nhất là phải gõ
được hai thứ tự Bắt đầu tìm kiếm này rồi
Khi mà khi mà chọn xong thì nó sẽ vào
đây nhưng mà đỡ nhờ chọn xong rồi mấy
ông thể hiển thị kiểu khác nó ngoạn mấy
ông giống như vừa rồi mấy ông thể kết
hợp thêm cả cái này để hiển thị màu mè
luôn đó ở dưới đã thích là cái dưới và
thường là chọn xong thì mấy ông về bắt
chước rồi ngày là nhảy sang kia cũng là
một cách gửi sang trang sản phẩm không ạ
Nhà tôi chỉ đã nói qua việc là bé ông có
thể làm được rất nhiều cái không ạ thì À
hôm cốt này về thôi thì mới Ông thấy à
nó luôn phải thêm chứ gì rồi kết hợp với
Uy này thì sẽ chantry Ui ở đây và cả CF
của nó nữa
Ừ ừ
nghĩa file này của tôi có thể hát Timber
thuần là tôi sẽ gọi đến file kia nhé để
tôi có tạm xóa này điện nhé
anh cho coi chia sẻ code mấy ông nấu
thành ra cứ xóa thôi làm rồi sao
à à à à
ở
trên thuyền tạo GV bạn trên đội được này
à
à à
từ nhỏ
Ừ để cách viết này cái viết tắt của đo
của mình vẽ đi nhá Tôi khuyên mày không
không hẳn cần lên không nên viết tắt của
Nga
mới học không nên tắt cái gì cả Mình sẽ
đi đầy đủ về đi thôi
anh ạ
em bỏ qua Phong trình lắc đi mình không
cần bóc à
Chúng tôi sẽ kết hợp cả hai cái chị một
cách màu men cho mấy ông sao Trung à khi
sẽ lách xong thì
ở chung bây giờ trước mắt thì mình cắt
hiển thị đã ngoại thì chị đến sót ra là
đây mình sẽ có cái á
Ừ cái
đít này
anh
nói thì quan tâm mới được là khi thái
mình sẽ gán ghép tôi cũng đi cho thằng
này không ạ Cái thằng coi đi này không ạ
Chị gà Nó nó có phải physis ngoan thì
tạo phải sợ rồi đây
à à
Ừ
cái tên mấy ông sẽ thấy ở ra ở đây nó
chưa chưa nói cụ thể là physis này nó sẽ
cần phải làm gì đó nho ạ thì ra nó sẽ có
dây cáp vào đây nhờ tôi không muốn tâm
Cứ giả sử là mình chưa biết được nó có
tác dụng gì cái chạy thử file này đã
Anh đang ở
tải cái gì mà lắng nhé
à à
ờ
ờ unexpected Network nhỏ này đó mới ông
sẽ thấy nó sẽ truyền sang bên ai một cái
khái niệm và tôm nha nó cần trả về cho
ông về nó cần phải trả về cái gì cũng
chậm thế
anh
ở đây là
Đạt key word hoặc cà sa đi bằng đôla
ghét ghét nhỉ Nhưng sẽ tốt nhỉ mẹ truyền
sang là dạng à
khi chuyển sang dạng gì đấy
ạ Bây giờ nói chuyện xong nhập pass
ăn gì thế
à À cái này lỗi Đúng rồi như thế không
chơi chạy trai nghe được phải vào hẳn
cái trang của tôi
chợ hoa hạn chẳng may em chạy đua của
việc Iraq nó không cho chạy à
à à em heo rất là không cho chạy ở trên
cái file file cẩu HTML gọi sang rồi file
cùng như thế
Ừ phải bảo hành vũ trụ máy ảo để mà chạy
chỉ mới được
à à
ở đó đây là ghét mày
khi chuyển sang có thể thứ cây rồi
Ừ Quan trọng bây giờ mình cần trả về cái
gì không ạ mình
đâu để tôi thử xem thử xem à
Anh nhớ nó cố cặp t mày nghỉ
à à
ở với tôi tôi nhớ có cả hút mẫu pp cho
mấy ông dễ hình dung
gửi tin nhắn
anh
không Thôi để tôi sẽ tượng cốt tự có vậy
đi quay này ăn mi này con ếch này p này
không nhỉ
yêu
cầu truy vấn đúng không ạ SQL bằng
selects out from from
where name
em là ai
phần trăm phần trăm không ạ đó xét
tuyển Nga
số kết quả trở về
nick
iCloud rồi mình trả về đây
à nhớ không nên là mình sẽ cho dạng viên
sân sao trả về cho nó là được
ừ ừ
thì mình sẽ có cái mạc
độ dữ liệu toàn bộ dữ liệu và
từng kết quả
nó chắc sáng mai
mình tự mình sẽ ấy zô
à à Vision and cost cài đặt hạ nghe đây
này là được nhưng không làm như thế
à à
mỹ phẩm Mỹ
tôi tôi tạm bỏ cái MI này nha mình gõ
cái tìm kiếm luôn nha à
à à
anh Kiên ơi Tại mấy ông thầy có thực ra
vừa rồi có hiển thị ra gợi ý
Ừ nhưng mà nhưng mà phải phải phải lấy
được theo kế Phi Của Nó phải lấy được
cái trường của nó
trường của nó là
thì mình sẽ có và lưu và level này lấy
bồ là hiển thị ra này ngoại I borrow có
thể thử
Ừ đợi tí nhắc đợi tí
những mẫu cửa sổ Lotus 09
ở ven đô
thì mình sẽ kết hợp luôn cả thằng này đi
như chen thêm cái
sẽ anh chị màu mè
ở
Tân lẻ về nhà
Ừ chắc không
Ừ thì mình mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ sửa lại
một chút
a cho mình sẽ có là truyền đây là để bồ
cho bộ
đồ là x tại nêm này tên sản phẩm tiếp
theo và lu
a tattoo đấy bản chất nó là
Có ai đi có sản phẩm
phần mô tả
để tôi xem lại cái đã tới bây giờ thu
phí xử với tao bây của tôi lưu lại có
những con nào rồi Đã có quốc giá ở quận
mô tả có những thời gian mô tả nó ra lắm
không có em lên hiển thị ra phần mô tạ
trước khi ông cắt bớt ở thật cấp chuỗi
bớt thôi hoặc là nó không tách hẳn ra
một của tồn tại
nhưng có bức ảnh đúng không Nhưng có một
cảnh bị ra cái ai
chỉ có một photo nữa đúng không
chúng tô này còn gì nữa nhá
khách hàng chỉ đơn giản thôi Chỉ cần
hiển thị ảnh của tên sản phẩm thôi cũng
được thêm giá những cạnh này cũng được
trong các bạn 13 này nhá Ờ
Ừ anh sẽ đi trong cái đít này có tên này
anh xuống dòng thì mình sẽ là cái anh
không ạ
chỉ cách viết này tôi thường anh viết nó
sẽ dạng kiểu như này chờ gì ờ
em
biết này à
chị
sẽ là hai tâm tại
label
sau đó thì bây giờ
Khi
dòng xuống dòng
mỹ sẽ có thể mgr C
Ừ anh sẽ sọ đến admin xuộc này
khi mua đất suốt
xe ô tô đúng ô tô
suốt rồi ạ
Ai tâm chấn photo
nhưng có triệu cao cho nó
hay chắn ạ
em tắt thế kỷ ai tầm value thì hãy bắt
đầu nghỉ
em bỏ qua
a snack kính hiển thị tại bến ngày cưới
a cuốn sách idea tôi để tôi thử xem lại
nhé ạ
ừ ừ
à à
ừ à Nó để ẩn phút hay ở đây
có một cái input ăn ở đây nó sẽ chọn
trong một cái input này nhưng mà nó sẽ
điền vào trong cái mua ẩn khi mà cái cái
Hà này là thế mà mình sẽ lách rồi nó
phải điền và ok ok cũng có một cái hay
khi được tôi sẽ bắt chước hàng ngày
à à
ở
đây
đổi tên lẻ xót ngoại trừ pp này à
à à
xin lỗi thằng ai thôi ngày thằng này sẽ
mình là tên nó là bước à Thế phố chắc
như được nó trước nó vô trách nha
I
thought I
Khi mà mình sẽ có cái phút Ẩn đã báo
trước nó sẽ có hai cái thằng ở đây 1
input Ẩn Và Tôi check ID
có chịu nghỉ à
à à
khi dùng hội để tiêu dùng mà ở
ở tại ok ok à
ừ ừ
khi mua track ID của Jack description
Channel description
à à
anh biết nhỉ cái xe lách này là chọn
xong ô tô con nít này nó nói cái gì nhỉ
à à Chắc là nó gợi ý gợi ý là lúc mà để
màn hình thị Còn khi chọn xong thì mình
cũng cần in nó ra nữa kể về
à à
ừ ừ
anh coi cần này
ý nghĩa là chọn lúc mà chọn này không
cần thị ra anh
em có cần đi
chị sẽ bỏ quay bỏ qua hàng Ai nói chị
biết rồi xong cần thôi I
a Cho các chất thải có bị hết hết đi
ờ ờ
bài viết này
à à
ừ ừ
khi mua sách level không bị ghi đè lên
Xóa đi Ai cần lúc đầu là không có gì cả
Anh đang bị trống
Ê sao Tao đi đây sẽ ghi đè lên
Ừ anh sẽ là amin à
à à
khi mua đất ở
xe ô tô
lấy sơn la photo ở Tân Tây Du Ký thơ
trong ngày đấy à
anh nhìn nhá
em heo trông hấp dẫn
ờ ờ
Em bận à
xin lỗi kìa lỗi mà
khi sex
à à
anh suốt admin phố Bắc à à thiếu à mà
chéo
đi tàu hỏa tốc
cho hay cho máy hài cũng mặc định là
200 người thứ hai bé hơn phải năm 20 50
Thì đó thôi
lại hiểu
Cô Bé Bán nhà thôi Bấm vào thì bị già
được chưa đó
anh
đúng không nó kết hợp cả live show cái
không phải ô tô con nít ở đây ông ạ Đấy
thì ta là mấy ông đương nhiên là chọn
xong thì mấy ông lên nhảy sang cha của
nó chứ không phải là để mà hiển thị ra
như này đây tôi đã đề mô mới ông là có
thể chị ra Mày Cái phút này và đơn nhân
bị ông sẽ thấy là nó sẽ có một cái inbox
hả hai lần đây nữa bạn Zalo nó được điên
theo ID có cái thằng mà mình vừa chọn
nóng lạnh
đấy Đấy vừa rồi cái hợp like đó tôi vừa
nãy tôi hỏi câu Hôm nay mày không trảm
sát thì cái hôm nay chậm đấy
cho tôi tôi hỏi câu vừa nãy Nếu không
trả lời
chị đánh giá sản phẩm này đánh giá đơn
hàng này mày không lưu lại trong bê như
thế nào
Ở
Đà vừa rồi thì cái là cũng nói mà nói có
ai cho mấy ông về thời ta có quạt ý sinh
trong này Đấy mày không để ý kĩ là tôi
trả về dữ liệu dạng vi sinh dạng như thế
này cơ cấu trúc nó như thế này tôi thức
mở cho mấy ông xem nhé
Ừ nó dậy xuân ờ ờ
Ừ thế Thế nào là một Vision thì reason
dị bản chất Nó là kiểu
nó Nó là kiểu dạng là nó khác với cái
mảnh mà mình thường ấy làm Nó kiểu nó
đối tượng hơn thứ nhất ở nó có một cái
khuôn khuôn mẫu của dạng Vissan ông sẽ
tra dư sinh này đã bịp skul trở lại để
nó giải thích từ dễ hiểu hơn nhá á
thế
giới thiệu này ai nó sẽ có làm một theo
một cấu trúc gì đó Có mát thì đó Và quan
trọng là tại sao lại rung rinh vì bản
chất là dữ liệu trả về cho cho cái việc
api như thế này hoặc trả về cho bất kỳ
trang web khác khi mà gọi đến đường link
của ông để ra sự Tìm kiếm ngay ngắn hạn
không ông phải có một cái cấu trúc chuẩn
một cái giỏ dạng là một cái định dạng
chung ấy để mà thằng nào cũng ta cũng sẽ
có thể đọc được thông tin từ trang của
ông nếu mà ông trả về theo cậu dạng là
ở dạng kiểu dạng là kiểu không theo một
cấu trúc reason không theo cấu trúc gì
cả ông già sử ông cứ printer nha Chẳng
hạn
như này
đề thi người người khác thì gọi đến
chàng uống sữa khó lắm Thậm chí à không
phải mỗi như thế này ông tự nhiên là ông
ấy cho ở đây
ra sự ông đây tôi thử ví dụ Ông thêm một
vài cái nữa thì ông sẽ thấy á
Duy Sinh nó quan trọng anh nhé à
Ừ tôi thấy rất nhiều rất nhiều lập trình
viên không biết cái sân gặp phải trả về
kết quả đánh giá tinh ra sự ông ấy cho
kiểu ngay
trả về đúng kiểu như này thôi ông cứ
muốn đọc nha Đọc như thế cách nhau bởi
dấu phẩy thôi chẳng ạ
hình ảnh
ừ ừ
ở
ngay đây ạ
cách cúng ông cách để trả về dữ liệu đấy
Nhưng mà thực sự thì mấy ông thấy thế
này mấy ông là sao hiểu được hàng ngày
thằng hai thằng áo thằng thứ hai thằng
nào thằng cuối hàng đúng không ạ Nhưng
sẽ phải cố đoán không ạ thì thay vì thế
thì cái reason là cách để mà kiểu lập
trình viên mình nghĩ ra nhưng mà kiểu
khi mà gọi đến một cái đường link một
cái kia để lấy dữ liệu về mình phải có
một quy chuẩn nào đó để mẹ ạ dữ liệu nó
sẽ phải theo một cấu trúc một phòng Man
gì đó để mình dậy dậy thao tác với nó sẽ
có khái niệm vợ dưới sân Thì mấy ông
thường để không chỉ cần gì xin em cốt
như này cái mạng của ông đó đã ra được
một cấu trúc di dân rồi nó sẽ có kiểu
dạng ngay
nếu không thì ra mấy ông chả cần quan
tâm đến việc là
là kiểu dạng và
vì nó có bao nhiêu thông tin bao nhiêu
trường ở đây là Vân người ông lấy nó ra
khá dễ khi mà dùng ra Swift để mà lấy dữ
liệu ra nếu chỉ cần dùng cái chấm như
này gọi đến thằng con của nó là được lấy
được dữ liệu của nó
ở cây các em nói chung cũng sẽ thấy anh
nói vừa rồi vẫn rất là nhanh vẫn rất khó
hiểu những cái video gần đây của anh rất
khó hiểu thì đương nhiên bởi vì cái này
nó hơi bị trâu 1 tí nhưng mà tôi đang
chỉ giới thiệu qua thôi những cái ông
nào mà đang ngồi mò này sẽ trả lời tôi
khẳng định có khi còn dễ hiểu hơn trên
đọc tài liệu của nó giống như vừa rồi
ông nào Tài liệu này có khi ông chả hiểu
tôi cố trong ông mới hiểu được hơn sợ
thằng Tài liệu mày thứ nhất này thứ hai
đó là
an toàn bộ Cái này nó vẫn hơi bị chuyên
sâu một tí à
Ừ cái này toàn bộ những kiến thức này
tôi sẽ nói đầy đủ và từng tận và chi
tiết hơn ở khóa sao Là sao Là khóa lập
trình web nâng cao dồi ngoại chuyên sâu
rồi còn khóa này thì cần Như là mấy ông
mấy ông nghe qua cái này với ông xem tài
liệu và có cốt về gần gần như vẫn chỉ
đại khái vẫn là KV là nhiều hơn mà miễn
sao nó chạy được những thứ chỉ thế nên
tôi chỉ nói qua các bạn mà ông không cần
nên
em chưa cần phải hiểu rõ thực sự Cái này
là gì và Vân thì cũng mới tiếp cận mà
làm sao mà áp dụng được nhiều để mà hiểu
không ạ Nhưng tôi chỉ nói một cách lướt
qua thôi yên tâm mà về sau tôi sẽ dạy
mấy ông kỹ về api này chẳng reason rồi
xong rồi không phải áo rách nữa mà cụ
thể nó là xr đấy Đó là kiểu gọi đến gọi
đến trang web khác đấy thông tin về
ở Đông ạ thì nói chung là những cái buổi
này thì mấy ông đấy Nó lỡ chuyến sau như
được ra
Ỷ Lan tôi dậy vẫn trong ở mức cơ bản
được đấy
Ừ nếu tự đáy mà ông vừa rồi thấy tôi
ngồi mò tài liệu đọc của nó bé uống thử
cốc lại về với mày chạy đâu nó ngọn
không có cả file
p-code mẫu cho béo người uống tham khảo
cơ em ấy ông chạy mắt không ạ thì
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok bây giờ thì tôi sẽ giải đáp cái câu
này bạn kia thì bảo lại trong cu lắc vào
đây anh em Thực ra thì ạ
chị cũng sẽ nói rõ cụ thể là cột nó như
thế nào đúng ạ thì ạ
à à
các bạn trong bảng phố đắt thì ra nó là
sai tại sao bởi vì a và khu đất của mình
không nên không
anh không nên lưu lại việc bây giờ là sự
ông lưu lại đứng nhà ông sẽ nghĩ là lưu
lại đánh giá của người dùng nó ạ đánh
giá nó là đa chị ạ không ạ không thể lưu
lại cột đa chị ông này vào đấy Cái thứ
nhất thứ hai là một khách hàng đánh giá
được nhiều sản phẩm mua sản phẩm được
đánh giá bởi nhớ lấy Hà Đông ạ Thế nên
hoàn toàn phải tách ra 1 bảng riêng là
bảng food review rằng ạ họp douglas tinh
ở Ngạn để mà lưu lại Friday cơ số 10 đi
và loại Sting cũng nhờ lượng comment thì
nó mới đúng sau đó thì đương nhiên là
mấy ông muốn hiển thị ra một sản phẩm
được à
em được bao nhiêu đây vì axit cho bé ôm
lấy chồng nha
bộ phim xe có phê Đắc ngoạn mình sẽ có
ai đi lên nhà đây sẽ có bạn là một mô
đất vết tinh được hả mình sẽ có
BlackBerry
Z10 đi Đấy trong trường hợp mà bắt buộc
Khách hàng phải đăng nhập có nhiều nơi
thì nó sẽ không yêu cầu khách hàng đăng
nhập cần điền có dùng nêm có sờ email
chẳng hạn ẩn danh như gì ấy
rất tinh này để lưu lại cái Sao vừa nãy
đúng loại con mà
số comment nữa
nha thi thì mấy ông muốn để xem được một
sản phẩm này có bao nhiêu bao nhiêu
Sting Nhưng mà ông đếm đếm trong cái này
dựa theo peroxide không ạ và tương tự
Thế mấy ông muốn xem mà mua sản phẩm này
được
kiểu trung bình trung bình nó ngoãn
thường ai tính trung bình thôi là kiểu
bao nhiêu sao thì mới ông chỉ cần đấy
dùng hàm tính trung bình nối sang bà này
rồi tính trung bình là xong Thế thôi ông
ạ
a tiếp theo đơn hàng đơn hàng lại khác
đơn hàng khác bởi vì a Tuy là
Ừ để cho nó khác bởi vì một một đơn hàng
có một khách hàng thôi mà một khách hàng
chỉ đạt được một đơn hàng à đánh giá cho
một đơn hàng thôi chứ khi mấy ông 15 chi
tiết giống kiểu nhiều thằng nó làm những
kiểu xô pi hiện nó sẽ đánh giá cho
từng sản phẩm đơn hàng nữa nếu không sẽ
làm và đánh giá cho
chị đánh giá vừa đánh giá tổng quan cho
cả đơn này vợ đánh giá cụ thể cho từng
sản phẩm
Ừ cái đấy thì là chơi luôn cả nó nhịn nó
thấy ra nó cũng nhảy sang phố Bắc đấy và
cũng ở phố đắt với tinh này đấy đấy
nhưng mà tôi nó qua việc đánh giá cho
đơn hàng thôi nhé Thì ngoài những cái
cột cũ ra thì mình sẽ có lại còn listing
ở comment thôi nhưng cái quan trọng ở
đây đó là mấy ông lúc đầu thì hai cái
cột này ổn nó được phép bị chống nó nun
và mấy ông và khi mà cái đơn phải thành
công rồi nếu một được phép đánh giá
không ạ những người ông lại phải kiểm
tra Giận hay sao tớ đấy Khi mà đã được
duyệt
kiểu đã được ship thôi Cái gì đó đã được
trao tận nơi khách Hà thì mới thì mời
cậu kiểm tra điều kiện ở bên trang khách
hàng để máy hiển thị hai cái này để thi
hành đánh giá ngoại nó không chuẩn mà
nhiều khách hàng đánh giá khi mà đơn cho
nó nhận đến hình giống như thằng
Cellphone S là thức gửi tin nhắn nó Tôi
đánh giá chất lượng của sản phẩm khi mà
hỗ trợ đến tai tôi bây giờ nào tội đánh
giá này cơ tiêu cực Tao chưa nhận được
sản xuất sản phẩm không tồn tại
ừ ừ
anh nói chung là kiểu à đây Đấy cách án
thiết kế tương đối tương đối thôi DB để
mấy ông làm cái vụ kiểu đánh giá
Ê mấy ông Thực ra cả cái vụ mà tìm kiếm
này nữa thích chị mày ông có thể lưu lại
được khách hàng đã nhập những tỉnh từ
khóa gì Tìm kiếm và khi bấm máy ảo Tìm
kiếm từ khóa mình vẫn lưu lại nhé nhưng
mà đang tìm kiếm cả là ờ
ở đây để tôi thử nói thêm tí một tí mở
rộng đã ơi sự phóng thích bà mặt kewell
đi à
ông xã và lụ ID
ẩm thực ra không cần này đi đâu và lưu
thôi
Alo là tất cả những cái người xuống đã
gõ và cái hay ở đây đó là các ID
cái hay đấy Tại sao Hay bây giờ sửa nha
Tôi vừa nãy tôi gọi cho iPhone gọi chứ
ai thôi cho iPhone và tôi ấn mà cái link
của iPhone này luôn iphone12 ạ Nó có Sẽ
id12 hạ đó tiếp theo lần sau tôi sẽ gõ
là dụ chữ f Samsung nha cho tôi sẽ ấn
vào là mười Nga
khi đó ngoại và đương nhiên là tôi sẽ có
thêm một cái cốt ở đây nữa cột cao để mà
đến được xem là cái cái cái cái gốc này
được dùng bao nhiêu lần đó ngoại tệ thứ
nhất
Ừ ừ
nếu thế thì tôi nghĩ là
Ừ đợi tí nhé
Em bấm vào Samsung nó vẫn có thể nhảy
sang phố đất khác cũng đã tính khác
Ừ Ừ Không Không Không sao Không sao
mình riêng trong trường hợp này mình sẽ
có 2 cột là khóa chính và lưu và flores
tại sao lại còn hai cuộc đời khó chính
bạn sẽ chờ
đi tìm kiếm key west thì được nó không
lặp lại thôi giờ sửa Nếu mà lặp lại cái
wed này thì cao tăng lên Không ý mình ở
đây nhá đó là mình làm mình làm cái bảng
này với mục đích gì để biết được là thứ
nhất ở khách hàng hay Gõ Tìm kiếm cái gì
thứ hai là khi mà khách hàng có tìm kiếm
đấy bản chất là khách hàng ba muốn bấm
vào sản phẩm nào nên thành ra là là sử
là trong trường này võ Samsung xong rồi
nó bấm vào cái Samsung Galaxy
mà IDM 15 ạ Đấy thì mình sẽ cao Nó tăng
lấy một con thích thì bé uống để tạo
xe máy miếu có thể à
Ừ thôi cứ tạm tạm rồi đấy nó tăng lên 10
ạ Sao Còn lần sau nó lại vào nó gọi
Samsung cho rồi lại bấm vào Samsung
Galaxy tiếp thì mẹ tăng lên hay không ạ
xong rồi nhưng mà lần sau nó vào cũng có
Samsung bấm vào Samsung Note chẳng hạn
thì ở đây bản chất là corradine khác
nghĩa là ngày mình phải đến nó lại bằng
một ngọn nghĩa hạ hai hàng ngày
cho hai thằng này trùng báo lỗi Còn nếu
mua chùm mỗi cái key word thì không đổi
không ạ
ừ ừ
cách tính trung bình Pretty nhá chị Trúc
Bình di tinh Viettel post ID do mình
dùng hàm trung bình em ạ
có bao nhiêu lượt 1 sao 2 sao thì
bạn sẽ Goodbye harass tinh này rồi Các
bạn cao thì có bạn sẽ đến được là có vợ
là với tần rating mình sẽ có bao nhiêu
thế được mà
Ừ đấy thì nói cho các bạn khi vuốt này
mấy ông sẽ thấy thôi có thể cùng chung
một vài từ khóa Nhưng mà khi mà khách
hàng gõ từ khóa
nào đó xong rồi bấm vào lại bấm porac
khác nó không sẽ lưu lại thì mày ông về
sau mấy ông sai sót lại cậu với cái sản
phẩm này thì thử keywords nào thường hay
được sử dụng đúng ạ đã sửa thứ không ạ
và đã được thích bao nhiêu lần để mình
có thể đẩy nói chung là rất nhiều cách
cái bi ển c Ủa mà ngọn rất nhiều cái cho
thậm chí nó còn lưu lại thời gian ở đây
cơ nó sẽ không dùng Cao đây nữa nó lựa
thời gian cơ nên nếu thế thì bạn này nó
nặng lắm với lại thời gian rất nhiều
nặng nên là tôi nghĩa đơn giản thì các
bạn lưu đại ca nghe thôi còn nếu mà các
bạn muốn làm lưu lại kiểu thực sự thì để
mà đánh giá được chi tiết ở khách hàng
như nào thì nó là cậu giống như ở công
ty tôi làm nó phải activitylog này khi
Active
tt5ttt ngon
Nó phải lưu lại hết toàn bộ người dùng
đã bấm mà bất kỳ cái gì cũng lưu lại
người dùng trỏ chuột vào đâu người dùng
Gõ cái gì bàn phím dùng thiết bị gì mà
uống lưu lại hết để V6 ông hoàn toàn tra
soát được là khách hàng đến bước nào mà
tự nhiên bỏ đơn và Vân dấu hiệu đấy
nhưng cái đấy gì quá chuyên sâu và nói
chung là cái tầm gì đó rồi chúng tôi
không sẽ không đề cập gì đây còn làm đơn
giản nhưng mấy ông căng nhất mình không
làm được cái này đã ngon rồi ông ạ
khi nãy vừa rồi tôi nói qua khá nhiều
Hôm nay thứ gà học khá nhiều kiến thức
đấy
đừng thắc mắc gì nhỉ Nhanh quá
Chỉ có mày miếu cứ trầm Trầm của gì 40
giờ xem kia là 40 giờ xem ảo ạ
thì alo điểm này nhé
Ồ sướng cho báo thầy cô mà mà điểm danh
mà ngon lém thơ tay thứ thứ
35649 là gì
Nói lượt mà tăng giảm được em ạ
số 1 là cái gì cơ điểm danh ở mùa này à
em không hiểu gì à Thế là thì à
Chính vì không hiểu nên mấy ông ấy hỏi
nhưng mấy ông hiểu rồi ra là cũng chẳng
cần phải hỏi không ạ tự nhiên nãy giờ có
thể là mấy ông không hiểu hoàn toàn
không hiểu lắm về cái việc nãy giờ tôi
đang nói nhớ em bé ông hoàn toàn thì
tháp mắt cậu dạng là bây giờ sự em muốn
làm cái abc rét thì làm nhà cũng được mà
nó ngoại
em có sức dậy xong quá này mình sẽ dạy
reserved
Ừ ok Nói chung ở bây giờ các bạn không
dám mắc gì bạn hơi bị đi sao mà Thì bố
mày sẽ tạm kết thúc của đây rồi à
thì các bạn cho người thắc mắc gì thêm
thì các bạn cứ bình luận hoặc nhắn tin
mình mình sẽ tổng hợp lại có hỏi vì sao
trả lời nhé
Ê thằng không được bố mày cứ tự đây thôi
mày cũng nhanh không ạ
thì tại sao bạn nha à